wir schauen aber zuerst in die usa
attacke von us präsident donald trump
gegen china es geht um das corona virus
bei einer rede vor der un teilt er jetzt
heftig aus und fordert die vereinten
nationen auf china wegen seines umgangs
mit der korona krise zur verantwortung
zu ziehen
sie werden das virus besiegen wir werden
die pandemie beenden und wir werden in
eine neue ära beispiellosen wohlstands
zusammenarbeit und friedens eintreten
während wir diese glänzende zukunft
verfolgen müssen wir die nation zur
rechenschaft ziehen die diese pest auf
die welt losgelassen hat china in den
frühesten tagen des virus hat china
reisen im inland gesperrt während flügel
china verlassen und die welt infizieren
konnten
china verurteilte meine reiseverbote für
sein land obwohl sie inlandsflüge
stornierten und bürger in ihren häusern
einsperrten die chinesische regierung
und die weltgesundheitsorganisation die
praktisch von china kontrolliert wird
haben fälschlicherweise erklärt dass es
keine hinweise auf eine übertragung von
mensch zu mensch gibt später sagten sie
fälschlicherweise menschen ohne symptome
würden die krankheit nicht verbreiten
die vereinten nationen müssen china für
ihre handlung zur rechenschaft ziehen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren